pour produire de la pâte et du papier
l'industrie forestière coupe des arbres
beaucoup d'arbres et elle génère
d'importants volumes de résidus qui
finit souvent aux sites d'enfouissement
mais il est possible de réduire la
quantité de déchets et d'en faire
profiter d'autres arbres
ces immenses rouleau de papier de
plusieurs mètres de large sont en vente
à la découpe
les feuilles seront ensuite emballé puis
livrer partout dans le monde
lusine de domtar à windsor fabrique
chaque année près de 650 mille tonnes
courtes de papier
pour produire tous papiers l'entreprise
a besoin de matières premières la fibre
de bois elle s'approvisionne en partie
sur les 160 mille hectares de terrains
privés qu'elle possède à proximité du
musée
depuis la fin des années 90 pour obtenir
un plus grand rendement en fibres domtar
a transformé 5 % de son territoire en
plantations de peupliers hybrides
dans de bonnes conditions
libre in pouces trois fois plus vite que
le peuplier naturel bas et si j'ai pas
trop vache 1
à l'aide de son drone filix brochu marié
supervise les travaux de plantation
selon ses observations
les premiers essais avec les peupliers
hybrides ont donné des résultats mitigés
car les sols acides du sud du québec
sont mal adaptés à la culture des
peupliers la populiculture
on a essayé pendant plusieurs années en
2000 2010 de faire fonctionner le modèle
du peuplier hybride en forêt sur des
terres qui sont très peu fertile trait à
ses très très difficile a planté on nous
disait qu'on réussit rapport
évidemment dans certains cas ont en
effet y avez raison on s'est trompé ça
n'a pas fonctionné
par exemple au pied des monts stocks
domtar a remplacé une forêt peu
productive par une plantation de
peupliers hybrides
dix ans plus tard la croissance est
anémique dans une partie du site les
arbres vivote et ont un diamètre d'à
peine 5 cm hauteur de poitrine
on anticipe même pas des bons fondements
ici en fait la régénération naturelle
doit s'installer le peuplier hybride qui
lui est fait pour pousser rapidement sur
un sol fertile n'arrivera pas à tirer
son épingle du jeu dans un site comme
ici
pourtant dans la paire celles qui se
trouvent à peine quelques mètres plus
loin des peupliers hybrides vigoureux
ont un diamètre d'une trentaine de
centimètres
même si tu m'aimes implantation 2011
même que l'on exactement on a un art by
6 pouces environ cinq fois plus vite que
l'autre côté
après 10 ans de croissance obtenue des
arbres avec des diamètres comme ça c'est
très intéressant dans un milieu foresti
qui à la base ici était pas très fertile
au départ
[Musique]
comment expliquer un si grand écart
entre deux parcelles voisines
la clé de la réussite se cache dans le
sol
une partie de la plantation a été
nourrie à même les résidus générés par
l'usiné
c'est quelque chose qu'il n'ait pas fait
ailleurs au québec est très peu au
canada en amérique du nord
quand les arbres sont récoltés le
procédé laisse derrière lui des résidus
des branches de la biomasse forestière
ils vont être récupérés mise en andains
broyer transportés par des camions à
l'usure
on va alimenter nos deux usines de
cogénération pour contrer de l'énergie
pour avoir un résidu qui est de la
cendre qu'on va t'amuser et on va le
mettre dans des camions et on va ramener
sans forêt ici
le traitement des eaux utilisées pour la
fabrication du papier génère lui aussi
des déchets des biosolides papier
une partie est maintenant récupérer puis
transportés dans les plantations de
peupliers hybrides
même chose avec les bouts de chou issu
du procédé chimique de la fabrication de
la pâte à papier
l'usiné de windsor génère environ 100
mille tonnes de résidus par année la
moitié retour maintenant en forêt
d'autres matières résiduelles sont
utilisés en agriculture
cette valorisation des matières
résiduelles permet non seulement de
fertiliser les plantations mais aussi de
doubler la durée de vie du site
d'enfouissement de domtar son quatrième
presque rempli à pleine capacité
ça coûte quand même assez cher parce que
c'est pas aussi un trou qu'on creuse
puis on met nos résidus vraiment on a ça
me prenait certificat du ministère de
l'environnement de l'autre camp les
changements climatiques ce que c'est
quand même très complexes comme
structure à bâtir et puis pour mieux y
avait des gros enjeux de coûts associés
à ces choses
[Musique]
ici une grande partie des matières
résiduelles est en transit
environ 95% des résidus de lusine sont
maintenant valoriser et le site
d'enfouissement sert aussi de lieu
d'entreposage le temps que les
biosolides pas petit bout lit de liqueur
verte et cendres soient transportés en
forêt
[Musique]
400 chargement sont acheminés dans les
plantations chaque année les pendants
vomir se charger dans sa benne qui
allait sur la future orientation pour
répandre le bios et des tapas type
[Musique]
des peupliers hybrides seront plantés
dans cette parcelle l'an prochain pour
la fertiliser adéquatement il faut
épandre l'équivalent de trois à quatre
camions bennes de biosolides papier à
l'hectare
les pandores forestier a été conçu
spécialement pour cette tâche il va
aussi avoir des cendres et les qui vont
être allé parler ici pour corriger le ph
par la suite on fait des monticules pour
recevoir les plantes qui vont être
plantés au début d'année prochaine
c'est ce qui a été fait l'an dernier
dans cette parcelle où un planteur est
maintenant à l'oeuvre
ici on voit ces deux là semblent qui a
été épandu sur la solitaire c'est la
seconde qui connaît là la condition du
bourg à l'usiné c du bios et les deux
papas tiff c'est un concentré de fibres
de bois qui est issu de la production du
papier s'est traitée par des bactéries
c'est de la matière organique pure qui
est appliqué sur le terrain si elle est
mélangée au sol dans les monticules
je pensais peut-être si la une une
deuxième fertilisation le chercheur
nicolas bélanger étudie les effets de
l'enrichissement des sols forestiers
avec les matières résiduelles
fertilisantes elles ont selon lui un
grand potentiel en populiculture donc
les bio seul et à petit et apporte des
nutriments alors que le bund shoah juste
pph ce qui est profitable pour
pau alcaniz et le sol et puis permettent
aussi de mobiliser davantage d'éléments
nutritifs
le spécialiste mesures notamment les
effets sur la croissance des arbres
la première année de croissance deuxième
année troisième année les résultats sont
très convaincants après 10 ans de
croissance on obtient à peu près 15 m en
hauteur si on n'avait pas fait utilisé
ici les résultats seraient beaucoup
moins imposants c'est à dire qu'on
aurait peut-être la moitié de la hauteur
on peut voir après 15 heures
lors des épandages on s'assure de
respecter des distances séparatrices de
10 à 20 mètres avec les cours d'eau et
les milieux humides et de 75 mètres dans
le cas des zones habitées
[Musique]
c'est important d'engager la recherche
de fonds de recherche et développement
de collaborer avec des chercheurs pour
mesurer tous les impacts que ce soit sur
la croissance ou sur l'environnement ou
sur la fonte sur la fréquentation des
cervidés des oiseaux dans nos
plantations
nicolas bélanger fait justement le suivi
de l'azoté du phosphore et des éléments
nutritifs qui se retrouvent enfouis dans
le sol est ce qu'on a observé ces qui a
tellement une croissance accrue
prélèvements accrus des éléments
nutritifs soit par les armes ou la
végétation du sous-bois qui a
pratiquement pas d'azoté et de phosphore
qui réussit à améliorer le à de grandes
profondeurs
donc tout est prélevé pratiquement ou
immobilisés dans le sol
et selon le spécialiste
cette forêt story intensive sur un
faible pourcentage du territoire permet
de mieux protéger le reste de la forêt
avec un système de plantation comme ça
on va pouvoir doubler
peut-être la superficie de conservation
non celle avantage conde c'est ça me
permet justement de produire autant de
biomasse ligneuse tout en gardant
la forêt pour d'autres usages que
l'exploitation forestière
ce modèle de sylviculture intensive
parmi les plus productifs au québec
pourrait bien faire des petits vraiment
des belles courses en otan-russie 1 mais
ce que le projet pourrait être exporté
ailleurs je suis sûr que oui
puis à des gens qui s'y intéressent qui
nous posent des questions d'ailleurs la
tude la stratégie de production de bois
du gouvernement québécois met l'accent
sur la plantation et la sylviculture
intensive
des essais de fertilisation avec des
matières résiduelles ont même déjà été
réalisés en forêt boréale où les sols
sont généralement pauvres
et les résultats s'annoncent prometteurs
temps dans les plantations de feuillus
comme le peuplier hybride que dans les
résineux
[Musique]